yesterday we told you about a family now
homeless as they wait for rental
assistance today Victoria Saha has some
Nation for those who are trying to get
answers from the program chat
[Music]
patience and hope is running thin for
Gwendolyn Clayton I feel like I found my
family as she waits for a final answer
from Clark County about her rental
assistance application she says she was
told to check every 30 days how many 30
days do you think I can give this before
it's too much for me the Clark County
cares housing assistance program also
known as chap was established early in
the pandemic for emergency help to pay
up to 18 months of rent after that's
used up you are no longer eligible
applications were cut off by January
22nd but Clayton was evicted while she
had an application pending since
December it wasn't about me I was a
number by January 23rd new applications
were being accepted only those who were
on a fixed income or facing eviction
were able to apply since then 5 000
applications have been processed as of
Tuesday more than 3 400 applications are
yet to be reviewed according to Clark
County residents with a pending chaps
application are not allowed to be
evicted for non-payments but Ryan
McConnell with legal aid center of
Southern Nevada says that can be a gray
area perhaps you have multiple denials
by a chat before but you keep reapplying
just for the sake of reapplying then the
Court's going to determine that while
you're not applying in good faith but
the future is still daunting for Clayton
our little bitty Cube here was our home
for most of the time
that we've been out here and may have to
be again
since chaps launched the county says
they helped more than 75 000 households
pay rent and utilities now this is a
lengthy process it takes three weeks for
processing and up to 12 weeks for a case
to be assigned to a caseworker